et attention là c'est un bon moment
selon ce sondage
si ce sondage dit qu'on doit continuer
je vous le dis j'enlèverai tous genres
est vrai toutes les tables tous les
tabous rit jaune à la foudre enlève tout
ils me disent on peut pas j'enlève tous
[Rires]
combien j'ai désormais tease et à la
montaison
[Applaudissements]
est ce que le public veut qu'on continue
puisque public aime chanter
est-ce que les audiences sont bonnes et
nora qui montre un message me chambrent
à seynod elle me mais c'est une blague
tu sentes de ouf mais de roof le gars
est chanteur [ __ ] d'ailleurs elle aura
ses nous regarde je passais non c'est
pas ça la confondant après une autre
chanson m'est témoin du fou je veux
c'est pas là que non non non non non tu
me proposes macumba en fait on n'est pas
chez moi que ses potes ses canards
macumba macumba c'est bien ouais vous
avez pas de kenji chantier aux jo dan
kenji c'est bien cangina lose all or
d'alou super lb non mais aussi belle que
jalouse des lions le roi cela balande à
l'ancienne garde de chez elle
on adore les chéris
battons tous poussé connaît là parce que
sur la prochaine chanson cheveux là je
veux je veux une fausse
[Applaudissements]